the last 50 years we've doubled our
population and four days there's a
million more people on the planet it is
the biggest crisis in human history the
niccola payment has prompted the
Federation to institute a one-child of
Family Policy and making a better future
for our children you plan on hiding this
moment we carve our names our 7:00
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday Friday
Saturday Sunday starting tomorrow you
will each get to go outside on a day of
the week that is your name Sunday will
get to go outside on Sunday on the on
Monday and so on
[Music]
outside of these walls you will all take
on the singular identity account set
what's your name hi I'm captain taran do
you have any siblings now
and wherever you are whatever you doing
you can never tell us all that you see
where the hell is she
what if Monday's hurt or dead and the
authorities find out before me gotta
help her I gotta go out there
[Music]
the etiquette is localized do not
underestimate segments
[Music]
[Music]
okay
together we will
hahaha
[Music]
you